You are listening to
radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. T. E. Yup.
So maybe you just want to start at the
beginning. So how did you bump into this?
Well,
you hate doing falling financial stories
and that I did some financial stories,
but I,
I think my beat was more people in the
headlines at the worst moment of their
lives and then I would go in and become
their friends and in the way we talk we
would talk intimately about what downfall
means when you've been at the mountain
top.
Hey, I'm Jen Abu Rod, I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab and today
the rest of Wall Street
legend or Lard Maydoff
a behind the scenes look at the
greatest financial fraud in history.
Billion Dolan Pyramids. Let's the hell
is going on here. Who is buying Milliken?
Tom have to wait. Come on by. I know
you got that money man. Whatever money.
It's a series called Ponzi supernova from
audible.com and she just set up how we
got to it. Ellen Horne,
the Great Ellen Horn,
who was one of the founding members
of radio lab a couple of years ago.
She left us, it was very sad for
us, but she went off to audible,
teamed up with a guy named Steve
Fishman who you just heard.
And together they produced this series
which has tape in it that has never
before been heard. And it's pretty
extraordinary and kind of, uh, you know,
given what's happened recently
with financial reforms up,
up for reconsideration, what you're
about to hear, you will find, uh,
a little bit troubling and
extremely timely. Yeah.
And so what we did a couple of days ago,
we got Steve and Ellen into the studio
to play us some stuff and to talk about
it. Yeah, sure. You spend the
first episode really, oh, sorry.
You spend the first episode really
chasing the guy trying to get access to
Bernie Madoff in prison.
Yeah. You know, I did all
kinds of things. I mean,
this was like years long pursuit.
I would send Bernie novels in the mail.
I would try and insult him.
I copied out Sartre's play, no
exit, and I sent that to him.
You know, just to try and get a rise. I,
I put money in his commissary
account and then, you know,
sent him a, you're welcome note.
Never receiving a response.
Do you know why at this point what
was driving this? I mean, listen,
Bernie has done this.
I mean everybody knows and we keep
reading about the details and we keep
triangulating Bernie from friends
who very obviously didn't know him.
Investors who filed easily, obviously
didn't know him. I want to hear this guy.
Tell me, I want to say Bernie. Why did
you do this? You were already rich.
Come on. What's going on here? I mean,
Bernie had the greatest seed in the
house to what was going on behind the
scenes. So uh, Steve has
explained to us for years,
he just kept pestering the guy
in Paris. Stubborn man. Yeah.
In a talking to like a whole
series of other prisoners,
asking them to get the word to Bernie.
And eventually just to cut to the
chase one day my home phone rings.
So I pick it up. It's a Sunday evening.
The jets came is on and I got my two
young kids running around and it's,
you have a collect call from an
inmate at a federal prison and then,
and then you hear Bernie's voice saying
Bernard Madoff in this kind of slightly
did kind of discussed it, a tone
of voice. And, and I was like,
Captain Ahab. But now you have kids
running around the room at jets game on,
here's the phone call. Oh my God.
Are you ready? Oh, and I'm not ready.
I don't have a pen and
paper. I don't have a,
a tape recorder and my kids
are in the background. So my,
my first reaction to Birdie on
the phone is, hey, kids shut up.
It's Bernie made.
So then it called comment only in
15 minute bursts. And um, then,
uh, the, for whatever reason,
yeah, exactly. 15 minutes.
Exactly 15 minutes. It just ends.
And then the inmate has to wait
15 minutes to call you back. Wow.
So he hangs up. I know I have 15
minutes. I'm running around him.
I must have a tape recorder and then
I find one in the closet. I, you know,
tested it.
Ada [inaudible]
at this point we're just
going to drop into the series.
Bernie. Yeah. You got, you got total in
the middle of saying something. Situate.
Just do it. I was so, it just got cut off.
Well yeah, I was just saying it was
great to talk to you because you know,
talking to you in person is so different
than reading about you all the kind of
caricature out there and the whole
sense of you as being a, you know,
just as one dimensional person.
It was nice talking to you too.
Stay there through all these years.
So it had been done.
So a burning made off is the greatest
financial crook in history questions,
but his voice is familiar to me.
Male or Madoff could be the
uncle I run into at Bar Mitzvahs.
We have common roots,
middle-class New York Jews and
also an interest in the jet
going up the game or you know, I got it
recorded. [inaudible] yeah, I like that.
I can [inaudible] if I want to. What do
you do? Are you near the TV room now?
Yeah, yeah. Just phones are
right. Right near the TV. Okay.
I tried to imagine the former chairman
of the Nasdaq at a pay phone in a cell
block, inmates lined up behind
him with prison Mae tattoos,
prison honed muscles. Oh, and you
can and you can call at night too.
Yeah. I call it til 10 30 at night.
Prison is not what Bernie expected.
The way depicted of you. You were over
the dope bars on the windows, you know,
with the doors that I blocked that night.
I a nice pretty big picture window.
Open it.
Yeah. I mean I guess aside
from being, you know,
separated from everybody in Weldon.
Oh, it's, you know, ain't my family
probably not talking at Ruth right now.
No, it's just uh, the whole
thing is uh, you know,
it's just, I look, I,
I know you'll never go.
Yeah.
Time's up. It's frustrating. A
call starts, we build momentum.
Bernie begins to open up and
then the guillotine falls.
Trust is tough to build on the timer and
I need to be the person he will trust
with the whole story,
at least as he sees it.
Bernie lets me know he has a story
to tell. He's been misunderstood.
I'm a good person. He tells
me he starts with this.
His family didn't have a clue.
Bernie insists he shielded
his family. No,
Billy kept them in the dark until the
unseasonably warm afternoon of December 10
Joe is sort of in a panic
about the whole all in thing.
He was at his office, Bernard l
Madoff securities, a family business.
What happened was [inaudible] came into
my brother during the afternoon and
said, what's wrong with that? Terrible.
It's just falling apart. Uh,
my brother came in 37, you know,
you have to call the boys and something
to call. They don't know what it is.
And I said, I will on my own. I did
that. I said, I can't tell them to you.
All of us is up, just gonna fall apart.
So, and I haven't heard from her.
She had no idea.
So we got into my car and we
drove a few blocks going drive,
drove into the new blocks to
the apartment. Fifth was hall.
We had bikes as part of that night.
They went into Bernie study,
that's what I broke down.
And I told them, uh,
crying and I played to him. [inaudible]
got all this money out and I, you know,
I'm not going to be able to recover it.
And I was crying, right. And
took me in his office and
felt sorry for me. Uh,
you know, I don't think it
is. Oh, totally. Fuck it.
Everybody was standing there talking, uh,
that I should have brought, I don't know
what else to tell you. I said, but, uh,
I don't know what you're supposed to
do now that I've told you this. So, uh,
and nobody gets angry at that point.
Everybody was fun that they were shocked.
I mean, it was, and they were shocked,
you know,
have you looked [inaudible] one day and
think your body is running this all a
billion dollar business and
everything is fine and he's happy,
they're happy and all of a sudden
the world comes crashing down.
Uh, they thought the is
the last time I have cried.
Like that was witnessing all.
When I found out my son, my dad's
Andrew, Bernie's youngest son,
had been diagnosed with
lymphoma five years earlier.
He fought it and recovered fully.
He considered changing jobs,
but Bernie talked him into returning
to work beside his dad, his brother,
his uncle, his first cousin.
The family all got along
well together and uh,
it was wonderful having them there.
I mean, we were very close family.
I was very proud of my son. They
were proud of me, you know, uh,
what I accomplished it like being a
Bagel off they hit and it was a lot of
recognition in that while I was respected
in the industry before this happened,
that they loved that and I love having
them in the business because it was
successful at it. I kept them
totally out of the loop. I mean,
I didn't want to do it.
I could let that be part of the loop and
now all of a sudden they feel as it was
this other side that
they didn't really know.
As for what happened next, the
afternoon, I told them all,
they immediately left. They went
to a lawyer. The lawyer said,
you gotta turn your father in a
way that in. I never saw them again
and didn't hear from them again until
two years into Bernie's 150 years
sentence,
his oldest son mark sent a message in the
most horrible way the chaplain came to
get you and what does he bring you to
the chapel and roots on the phone and she
tells you?
Yeah,
I cried for a well over
two weeks after he die.
Mark Madoff killed himself at age 46
hung himself with a dog leash in his soho
loft while his toddler
slept in the room next door,
the date December 11 2010 two years to
the day after his father's arrest to
Burnie. Mark's message to him
was clear, you ruined my life.
I tried. I tried in private
because I didn't want to do it.
[inaudible] if they switch over,
they probably would've put date
cause suicide squad is what they do.
They all worried about me.
They woke me up every hour on the hour
to make sure that I was okay to God.
I was a basket case for four weeks and
Bernie told me he still hoped he
could reach Andrew and explain.
But Andrew's cancer returned. He blamed
the relapse on his father's crimes.
The stress and shame of it
all. Andrew Madoff died in 2014
I have tears in my eyes and I've told
my views about certain things are not a
day goes by tonight. I don't stop
her. It sounds okay on the phone.
Trust me, I'm not okay. You never will be.
Bernie though is a survivor.
Once he confessed to the largest
Ponzi scheme in history for him,
the worst was over.
It must have been something of a relief
to finally be able to get this off your
shoulders.
Oh, it was IB. I wish that
I would've caught earlier.
I was under tremendous pressure.
It was, it was absolute.
It was a nightmare. Only for me.
It was only a nightmare for me.
Yeah. I mean, you were looking down the
barrel of this for you. I guess you,
you Kinda knew it would end up here.
Uh, you know where you are now.
Sooner or later.
It's what I say,
nightmare [inaudible] imagine not being
able to tell anybody that I destroyed
the family. They said, why did
you need to do this? And I said,
I don't know.
Yeah, see me. That's what I try to
stick around here once a week. Yeah,
the psychologist, I fortunately,
they have a wonderful psychologists here
and they're very helpful to me. Wow,
that's great. That's right.
Believe me. That's great.
I have pupil sessions with her every week.
The New Yorker and his shrink seeking
reassurance, searching for answers.
Where does a monster come from?
I asked him, am I a sociopath? Privacy.
You're absolutely not a sociopath.
They said you have borrows,
you have Rabois
I came to think of my conversations
with Bernie as a kind of session too.
So I, I, Steve just, I
mean I'm just curious.
W what are you thinking at this
point as you're talking to, I mean,
we're running through his story and we've
developed the kind of rapport, I mean,
you know, there's a different
generation, but Jewish roots,
New York area. This is a guy
who's familiar to me and I,
and we develop a report and Bernie kind
of tells me the story of his father and
of how he got into this.
I bought it, built a sporting
goods business. He owed the top,
they called dodger sporting
goods dented, but as a joke,
a little too punching page.
Right, on a metal rods. Yeah.
And the a big successful business.
And then during the Korean
War it was a skill shortage.
She couldn't get steel
and it is business fail.
[inaudible]
so you know, I lived through that. You
Watch that happen, you see your father,
oh boy.
You idolize your build a big business
and then everything you fight about,
uh, you know, bad, something
like that happening.
Bernie was determined to attain
success, lasting success.
The kind that had alluded
his father, whatever it took.
I started the company in 1960
[inaudible]
22 years old.
He convinces a handful of
investors to trust him. Friends,
parents, former customers of his
high school, lawn sprinkler business,
clients of his father-in-law's
accounting firm.
The first thing I did was I
participated in a couple of Zulu issues.
New issues were hot in the 1960s though
without the mad scramble and hype of
today's IPOs. Back then there was no CNBC,
no computers with new issues.
He thought he'd hit on a moneymaking
strategy and then the Walgett
correct the 62 with the Chub
and missile crisis. Right.
The whole noise should walk
and wedded to the cane.
Bernie lost almost all of his
clients' money as he tells it.
He was embarrassed. He was in
tears. We took them to her father.
Bernie begged for a bail out.
His father in law saved him.
Bernie needed a better strategy.
We looked for a list of places
where we could have a ditch.
The odds were against
him as he sought Bernie.
Wasn't one of the Wall Street elite.
Did they make that clear that you know
you're, you're not in the club and,
Oh yeah. I mean it was obvious to
everybody. I mean, everybody knew it.
You know, we were a small firm. You want
to remember the duo stock fishing age.
You know, it was very obvious.
Steve says that idea like of Bernie as
that as a lower class kid from queens who
wanted to prove himself to the big
boys and be accepted. Steve says,
that's one of the keys to really
understanding how a guy like Bernie Madoff
could have gotten into
this gigantic fraud.
Because when Bernie's business
started to really take off,
possibly increasingly through fraud,
all of a sudden he had all of these guys
from the big banks calling them up and
wanting to take him out to lunch.
By the mid nineties word had spread
people clamored to put their money in
Madoff's IAA business.
So I opened up the individual accounts
on people and I started thinking of these
funds.
She Funds Bank funds and feeder funds
created to funnel money to Madoff who
pumped out those incredibly
consistent returns.
So all of a sudden, if you
have all these major banks,
it's flattering. It's
flattering too. All right.
Yeah, of course it is. It feeds your ego.
I mean, you know, you say to yourself,
all right, all of a sudden these banks,
which would give you the time of day,
all of a sudden they're willing
to give you affiliate dollars.
I had already major banks
coming down and the treating me,
it isn't hard trip.
Everyone wanted to be with Bernie
country club golfers, hedge funds,
prestigious banks.
So they, they, they study if they should
have been given, start out or fun,
you know, but we need you to give it to
the bunny. No, he, okay. I, you know,
I think I can do it cause I thought that
even if I started the short form of the
stock to them, we just see a matter
of weeks or months and you know,
I'd be able to recover from it.
According to Bernie, this was the turning
point. The market went against him.
The boy genius failed. And the delusion
of money, that was his undoing.
He couldn't move billions of
dollars in an out of market. My
mistake was I just should've left it
at that. Instead, these partners just,
you know, just get up pouring money into
me. And it was very hard to turn down
irresistible for the young
man once shut out of the club.
I mean, I guess the other thing
there is, you know, we'll,
you had a history of uh, you
know, breaking up the, uh,
the country club at the New York Stock
Exchange with the market makers and uh,
you know, now in some
sense I guess you're,
you're finally getting the recognition
from those kind of same people that uh,
they need you.
Yeah, that's right. And
then it just, it just,
the whole thing sort
of spun out of control
then let me just, can I get something
out of the way till Ponzi scheme,
which we sort of need to know Ponzi scheme
is I give you money to invest. Yeah.
You pretend you invest
that money but you don't.
Instead what you do is you go out and
you get new investors, take their money,
give it to me,
and then you go out and get even
newer investors take their money,
give it to the ones before
them and on and on and on.
So like all you're doing is
just repositioning money.
Like taking it from the new guys,
giving it to the slightly less new guys,
making it look like you're trading when
you're not and it only works as long as
you have new people coming in.
You have need a constant stream of
new people coming in with new money.
But that all sort of fell apart in 2008
2008 when we had a huge stock market
crash, Bernie woke up after decades.
He was getting a lot of money in.
All of a sudden one day people said, I
want my money back. That's true. Me Too.
Me Too.
And he had not done anything except expect
more money to come through the front
door on that day. There was no
money coming in the front door.
It just, the whole thing
sort of spun out of control.
And so Barney's version,
the fraud started because impressive
people threw money at him.
A good person who made a mistake
and we spend hours talking about this
and it seems to me at some point that
there's always going to be that next phone
call. But there's that gap, you know,
15 minutes. I have to wait
until the phone rings and,
and one time the phone doesn't
ring. Bernie doesn't call back.
And I get from the prison a letter
basically explaining that I have been
declared a security risk.
What is a security risk mean?
I have no idea. And you know, it's
some kind of catchall. I mean,
I tried to appeal that to the bureau
of prisons that it's unappealable.
So basically the warden says, you know,
we don't want this. There's a hassle,
you know, he's a security risk. He can't,
don't, and, and, and, and just to
synopsize just so at this point,
having spent a hunk of time,
you, you went into this thinking,
okay, I'm going to sit in his
shoes and I'm gonna feel him.
And where are you right now at this point?
So now I've spoken to him for
three or more hours. And you know,
I've taken this journey with him.
I've heard his story. I know you,
I have felt some empathy for
Bernie from his point of view.
And so now I start to
listen to the tapes and I,
I start to really kind of dig in and uh,
and it occurs to me that
Bernie's telling me two stories.
Bernie Madoff on one hand is this wizard
conducting this incredible financial
criminal wizardry, a master mind. And on
the other hand, he's this kind of pawn.
Aw
Huh. Not a word you normally
associate with Bernie Meda.
No.
And actually that's more on that after
the break because what ends up happening
and where the cool revelations of the
series is the way in which Bernie actually
sees himself
as a victim and it's here where the
story sort of starts to expand beyond him
and you start to sort of see the
much bigger field of play. Yeah.
That's coming up after the break.
This is Alicia bridges calling
from Saskatoon in Saskatchewan.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm
Robert Krulwich Radiolab. Today,
we're playing a series of excerpts from
a brand new series from audible called
Ponzi supernova comes from reporter
Steve Fishman and Ellen Horn,
our former executive producer. And
uh, it's a series about Bernie Madoff,
the largest financial
fraud in history. Uh,
it's sort of a behind the scenes look.
And in this series there's lots
of really kind of crazy frankly,
descriptions of how Bernie Madoff and
his team pulled it off and how on many
occasions they almost got
caught for me, right? A US
attorney,
Matthew Schwartz told me about one
of the closest of the close calls,
one starring Frank Dipascali Madoff's top.
Lieutenant Dipascali
testifies that he's, you know,
sitting in a conference room with
the auditors. They ask for, uh, this,
this report called us
Siack s I a c report.
So picture it a conference
room full of auditors,
one asks for this routine report,
something a legitimate trading firm
would have on the shelf. Of course,
Madoff isn't a legitimate trading firm,
so they don't have it. Think quick,
frank, and be cool in
front of the auditors.
Frank phones the computer
programmers and says, Hey,
can you bring up the siack
report? And the guy says,
basically the psych report, you told
us we didn't need the psych report,
where the hell am I going to get a
psych report? And he says, great,
I'll see you in 10 minutes,
you know? And then he does,
as he described it, a little soft
shoe to stall for time. Meanwhile,
the team has minutes to a false report
and then make it appear as if it's been
idling on a shelf.
They're frantically putting together
and printing out this report,
which is, you know, it's, it's
half a foot thick off for time.
Meanwhile,
the team has minutes to prepare a false
report and then make it appear as if
it's been idling on a shelf.
They're frantically putting together
and printing out this report,
which is, you know, it's,
it's half a foot thick of this
being paper Dot Matrix paper.
And then it's supposed to be a report
that's been lying around for a month and
instead it's hot off the presses.
So first they stick it in a refrigerator
that's down in the investment advisory
business to call it off and then
they literally play football with it.
They're tossing it around the room to
one another to make it look weathered and
then they run it up to a
two deep pascal [inaudible],
the Pascali. Here's the siack report,
who Cooley hands it to the auditors.
There are close calls over and over again.
It's fabulous theater. Steve actually
described a Bernie Madoff's operation,
right?
You know that created like this massive
$65 billion fraud as like super rickety,
basically held together by tape and safety
pins and old dot matrix printers and
they're serious.
Goes into a lot of detail about sort
of the mechanics and how it worked.
What caught our attention was the thing
that we sort of mentioned before the
break, this idea that Bernie saw himself,
not as this like all
powerful criminal mastermind,
but as kind of a pond. Yeah.
There was an original group of investors
that Bernie made up found and this
group is called the big four.
That's exactly right. The big four.
They came to be known. Even
Madoff calls them the big four.
I had four prime big
clients, Jeffry Picower,
Norman Levy,
Carl Shapiro and Stanley Chase,
commonly referred to as the big four.
He was very clear that those
accounts in particular Shapiro Levy,
um, pick cower and chase, former
assistant us attorney, Matt Schwartz,
again were handled very differently from
other accounts and were handled it in a
way that, you know,
it mattered less if there was
a mistake for these accounts.
The workmanship was quite
different, more demanding,
less exacting.
Some employees were more meticulous
than others and some clients you could
afford to be less meticulous with
a net bond. Juno had
been there a long time.
She was employee number
one in the Ponzi business.
Garfinkel told me she handled
the accounts of the big four.
Steve Garfinkel was one of the FBI
agents who investigated Bernie Madoff's
operation in nets clients
the way she for gazy their,
uh, account statements.
There were some instances
when the customer's got their
accounts statements from
net and complained that, oh, am
I, you know, you promised me,
uh, you know, 18% and I only got 16%.
And they sent the s the
statement back to Annette.
So then she would do a new statement
when miraculously you got the,
uh, you know,
your new statement with the new
higher return made off himself,
says the accounts of the
big four were for Gazy.
They were doing all sorts of Schmader,
a trays to Jewish term that we
used where they were, you know,
taking Los tres and the, the stuff
that they did was unbelievable.
And I were doing it through me. Hey,
demanded Bernie do kinkier maneuvers.
Stanley chase for example,
there was explicit testimony that he would
not tolerate a single losing trade in
his accounts.
And he had a particular trading strategy
where some times you could have a
losing leg of a trade with the
trade as a whole, as a winner.
Cause it was a three legged trade.
He wouldn't even tolerate
that for some reason.
Every single trade, every single leg of
every single trade had to be a winner.
Well, that doesn't happen in real life
and no one can demand that of their money
manager,
each of the big four,
pay back millions and pick ours
casing billions of dollars.
Every one of them claimed
Madoff had duped them.
They weren't prosecuted
and it's impossible
present return in a good year,
but no one has the ability to rewrite
history and turn stocks into bonds.
And so these men, mostly older,
powerful mentors to Madoff open for
me a new door into the Madoff Ponzi
operation.
They gave Bernie his break and then
demanded that he provide them things he
couldn't honestly achieve.
These people are these people,
and by that I mean the big four,
whether it's them personally or
their lieutenants or whoever it is,
they are asking for things
that are not possible, right?
Bernie is accomplishing those
things. So now ask yourself,
who has the power in that relationship?
Is it Bernie because he knows he's
doing illegal things for these parties?
Or is it the the party who set, who's
now making Bernie do illegal things?
It's both of them were. When
Bernie said to you, gosh, like I,
I discovered that people
are really greedy. Remember
that was in the beginning.
Is this what he means that
these people were using him?
This is what Bernie means. And,
and Bernie has actually a particular
enmity for those big four.
One of them, Jeffrey, pick
our, took out $7 billion,
$7 billion. This theme right
beyond what he invested. That's
Ellen Horn who produced the series.
Now the story of Jeffry Picower is one
of the more dramatic moments in the
series.
What's going on? Collab.
[inaudible]
10 months after Bernie Madoff's
arrest, Barbara Picower wife of Madoff,
the largest investor, Jeffry
Picower dialed nine [inaudible]
there is at the bottom of the pools at
the bottom of the pool that boom, okay.
This call was hard to
listen to. It's upsetting.
Okay. See, I'm a lot, I'm gonna start
the medics. You don't hang up. Okay.
I'm going to put your
tickets away for charter.
The fact that Jeffry Picower had a
heart attack and drown in his pool.
You can congratulate me on that.
[inaudible]
according to Madoff, the fort pick
out where it went for his final swim.
Bernie phoned him.
I called up Jeffrey pick
ours and you know, I said,
you got to give him
the money back. I said,
you guys owe me money and
I want the money back.
Pick hours, you know, sit there. Well,
you know, I don't have it all I did.
I said, Jeffrey, I know that
you have the money there is,
you're worth $9 billion
and I want 7 billion back.
Consider what made offs tone regarding
the death of someone he knew for decades.
What this says about
Bernie Madoff, who he is,
whenever someone hears that I interviewed
Madoff, they always want to know,
does Bernie feel remorse?
I've interviewed serial killers, child
rapists, people considered monsters.
I suspended judgment.
I wanted to hear their
stories to understand them.
This doesn't mean I wasn't
horrified by what I heard,
but I tried to see the world through
their eyes and exercising empathy.
At times I feel empathy for Bernie,
but here's what struck me about
Bernie. He didn't feel empathy.
He claimed to feel remorse.
He mouthed the words,
but there was always a button.
Oh, a lot of my clients get a fiddle
with every penny they put in there,
please poverty, don't let me up.
Excuse me. What I did, I mean,
I don't feel sorry for you.
You have a certain to
be a client. I would.
They were told Time and
time again that you know,
stop put more than 50% of
their marketable right.
With justice with me and with the odd,
all that combination and all
their statements, they saw it.
There were things that they sign that
basically they do that this kind of
trading is speculative. Eventually
they had doubts. They had doubts.
[inaudible]
on the phone with me every
single time Bernie mentions victims,
he can barely get through the
apology before interrupting himself.
They were warned. They were
greedy. Always this strange, sorry,
not sorry.
Yeah. I said brokerage firms can fail.
I could go crazy and do
something stupid. I said,
it's, you know, if you
want a guarantee, you know,
put your money in government bonds.
It's impossible to tell the story of
the fall of the house of Madoff without
understanding that there were
real victims. Real suffering.
Back in early 2009 victims were telling
stories of their ruined lives on TV,
on the radio, on every local talk show,
there was the worst thing
that ever happened to us. This
can't be real. We have lost everything.
I have lost everything and you've lost
everything. Everything that we worked for
goes down the drain at the end
and dumpsters.
Now, of course, you listened
to them. They're old.
They're living at a dumpsters
and they're, uh, they, you know,
they don't have any money. It's
on its own and I'm sure it's a,
it's a traumatic experience
for some, but you know,
I made a lot of money for a lot of people.
Did you catch the remorse or was it
too fleeting to register in your brain?
My producers and I were in touch with
dozens of victims to the victims.
Bernie's indifference was
in raging all over again,
but it wasn't the
slightest bit surprising.
What is surprising is what happened to
victims since Madoff dragged their $65
billion down a dark hall. I mean
there is now, this is eight,
nine years later,
there is an industry that is
created around the Madoff collapse.
There are hundreds of lawyers
working on recovering money,
and that's a very complicated story.
And, and when we try and tell,
because you know what,
a lot of people who lost money
didn't have any inclination,
couldn't have had any inkling
that this was going on.
So the justice group comes in,
private lawyers, courts, judges,
the Justice Department, and
they tried to make amends,
have they, justice is a
fairly complicated issue.
And the universe created by Bernie Madoff.
You have a trustee appointed
to recover funds for victims.
Well,
some of those funds went to people
who took those funds in good faith.
They'd given Burnie millions of dollars.
They took out a million plus one.
And so they thought they
were doing the right thing.
They thought it was their money,
but we've got to give money back to the
people who lost more money than they put
in. You're going to have to
give some of your money to them.
So it's a very complicated
moral universe. Well,
there's the individuals and then in the
last category there are the banks and
the investment institutions that sold
Bernie to ordinary people all over the
world. Yeah, there are these
financial institutions,
hedge funds raised billions of dollars,
took them to Latin America, to Europe,
all across the United States market
and in Bernie Madoff as a safe bet.
You know,
he was weaponized by the financial system
and so we wondered why weren't those
hedge funds accountable for not doing
their job and this is the still still
happening. Still
unraveling. Still needs to be
reported part of the story. Absolutely
[inaudible]
that question about why the people who
quote weaponized Bernie Madoff haven't
been punished yet probably
will never be punished.
That is something that Ellen Horn and
Steve Fishman tackle in the final episode
in their series. And we
definitely recommend you check it
out@audibledotcomslashponzisupernovawilllinkyouthereaswellfromradiolab.org
and
thank you to Steven Fisherman and to
Ellen Horn for sharing this work of theirs
with us. Also, a shout out to
producer Kelly prime, who, uh,
helped Ellen Steve Work on the
series here. So thank you audible.
Thank you for listening. I'm Chad Abu
[inaudible]. I'm Robert Krulwich. Uh,
we'll see you. We'll see you next time.